Awesome.
[Silence]
My hand
was Muhammad
[Silence]
are in
the chap.
But
really
one is preferred if you are traveling or
if a person is ill and they are able to
fast.
Which is preferred?
And
and this as we've mentioned before is
where the majority of differing takes
place. When we look at the differing the
differing amongst the scholars of Islam
to an untrained eye, you might open a
book of fick or you might open a book
regarding the differences of opinion or
even many fatawa and a lot of fatawa are
not written for the general public.
They are very localized and they are
written for a very specific
u set of people. most fatawa are
written for students of knowledge
explaining details. But when you look at
these fatawa, you look at these books
and you see all this differing of
opinion. The scholars differ on this and
the scholars differ on that. An
untrained eye might confuse this to mean
that most of the
rulings of Islam are differed upon
and that is very far from the truth. We
mentioned before that roughly 85 maybe
even 90%
of the legislations of Islam
alhamdulillah are agreed upon. Where
does the differing happen? in the
details. And a lot of the differing
doesn't even happen in one saying yes
and the other saying no or one opinion
saying halal and the other saying haram
or one saying and the other saying must.
This is extremely rare. This is called
differing that is in direct conflict of
each other. actually most differing
between the scholars is which is better
which is worse which is preferred
right I'll give a good example for
instance when you look at the mahib
and the placement of one's hands in
salah
okay in bkari the companions
mentioned that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would place his right
hand over his left and Bkari left it at
that. There are more detailed narrations
but he left it at that narration.
Now when you look at the madib where
does the differing come in? Is it some
say the left should be over the right?
Never. You'll never find that opinion.
Rather what you find is some say on the
chest, some say between the chest and
the stomach, some say on the navl, some
say above the navl, some say below the
navl. And so the issue is that the right
on the left,
right? And the issue beyond that is an
issue is more minutia, right?
whether a person puts their hands above
or below or on or what have you.
The narrations in this mention all of
that all of the above which tells us
that the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
often placed his hands in different
positions in his salah. The point is is
that there is no differing really on the
essence. The essence is agreed upon. The
differing occurs where which is better,
which is best. Is this better or is this
a little better? Or if something is
haram, which is worse, is this worse or
is this or is this something that
reaches the level of obligatory
or is it something that is merely
preferable? Is this something that
reaches the level of haram or is it
merely mak or discouraged? Right?
This is where the differing happens
which in itself is a miracle because how
many rulings are there in Islam?
Thousands.
Thousands upon thousands. And the
prophet Muhammad sallall.aii wasallam
never sat down and wrote a book from A
to Z.
But his life and his words are the most
studied words of any human being to ever
walk the earth. And for that reason,
Allah has blessed us as well with the
best of companions to that prophet, the
best of companions to those companions
and the best and most honorable scholars
and the brightest minds that the earth
have that humanity has ever produced.
And so we have without having a
centralized
head figure, right? We we should have a
Khalifa, but even in absence of a
generalized Khalifa, we don't have a
pope, right? We don't have a a person,
one figure head. Yet in spite of that,
it is the least differing ummah from
amongst all the nations that were given
a book of any follower of any prophet.
And so the differing is not inal
and haram. The differing is usually in
what? The details. Here we have one of
those details and that is that the
author says
with respect to the the ill person who
is ill or the person who is traveling
which is better for a person to break
his fast and take the allowance or for a
person to go ahead and fast if they're
able to.
The author says
The author says, and remember this is
mostly
the opinions of
as this book is really
a summary of and an authentication. It's
a it's a little different than a
summary. He says that if the person who
is ill or traveling does not find it
difficult, does not find it overwhelming
to fast, then fasting is better. But if
a person finds it to be difficult,
unbearable,
strongly, very uncomfortable, right?
then breaking one's fast is better for
this person person who is ill or the
person who is traveling.
So we might say well where does that
come from? Of course
in the month of Ramadan the blessing of
fasting during that time is going to be
superior than outside of that time.
Second of all, fasting with the people
that are fasting as a unit is going to
be much easier and better than fasting
alone. Third of all, delaying any good
deed is not preferred if a person is
able to do it sooner or earlier. For
these reasons, these general reasons and
for the evidences that he will cite, he
arrived at the conclusion that he did.
What is that conclusion? If a person is
traveling or ill, if they don't find it
overly difficult,
then to fast is better than to break
one's fast even though a person has an
allowance. Now again
breaking one's fast is agreed upon to be
permissible amongst all the scholars.
It's in the Quran clearly.
However, which is better? This is where
our discussion is today. He says
Ramadan
for
[Silence]
Muslim
im Muslim. him collected a narration in
his authentic compilation on the
authority of alud.
He said, "We used to travel with the
messenger of Allah.
Wasam to battles during the month of
Ramadan.
And of us, those amongst us, there were
those who were fasting and those who had
broken their fast. This is in Ramadan.
They're traveling. Abu says, "And so of
us were those who were fasting and those
who were not."
And those who were fasting would not
hold it against those who were not.
Nor were those who were break had broken
their fast would hold it against those
who were fasting.
The companions were of the opinion, a
generalized opinion, that whoever
felt the ability and had the strength to
fast and fasted, then that is good. And
whoever felt
some kind of weakness or need to
break his fast and broke his fast would
and that is good as well. This is how
the companions were.
So we see that they would travel in
Ramadan to go to jihad. I mean imagine
if you or I were going right now
to battle in Ramadan. Would most of us
break our fast? You might
die.
These might be your last days on earth,
right?
Many of us would
probably fast.
However, even under these circumstances,
going to battle in Ramadan
with the messenger of Allah sallall.aii
wasallam. Of the companions were those
fasting, and of them were those who were
not fasting. And neither would hold it
against the other, nor would any view
himself superior to the other. It's an
allowance.
now this is the companions of the
messenger of Allah. Fast forward to
today.
Especially us guys, you young strong
back man gets on a plane with his Muslim
brothers to go to in Ramadan
and the stewardist comes down the aisle
with breakfast. And then everybody is
sitting staring forward. Nobody wants to
say anything.
Everybody is looking at the corner of
their eye. Right? There are those who
want to break their fast. There are
those who have broken their fast, but
they wouldn't dare do that in public.
Why? Because you will be mocked and
yelled at and insulted and accused. How
dare you break your fast in Ramadan? I'm
traveling. What kind of travel is this?
This isn't traveling.
This is comfortable.
In the prophet's time, travel was
difficult. You had to carry the camel on
your back and you had to trek through
the desert and you had to This is
nothing but ignorance and it is what is
killing us as Muslim.
This kind of extremism on that. Yet
those same people, if you were to follow
them back to their homes, they deal in
ribba, they deal in pork, they deal in
alcohol, they deal in smoke shops, they
deal drugs, they But don't break your
fast in Ramadan if you're traveling.
That's a big no no. See, and this is
what is killing us as an ignorance
and shaming one another in a constant
manner. Not with the sense of I want to
help my brother rise to my level. In the
sense of I want to step on my brother's
head and prove my superiority at every
turn. This is something that we have to
stomp out of our communities. How do we
do that? Well, we don't start with
across the water or down the street or
up the road. We start right here in our
own home. We teach each other and we
learn a culture of the sunnah right
here. Right here in our little masid, we
start to learn a culture of the sunnah.
A culture of the sunnah to where our
children grow up not knowing any other
way. Right? This is how Islam is
reinstated and knowledge is reinstated.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
at 6 tomorrow.
Tomorrow morning will be at 6 and we'll
announce it a few more times but
starting tomorrow will be at 6. So if
you come at 6:15 you will catch us
saying